per la senti ragazzi e benvenuto questo
nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo
tornati sua o amici ho messo pochissimo
a fare il suo secondo episodio perché lo
adoro c'è a me piace il gioco quindi
ragazzi non ce la posso fare ad
aspettare per farlo abbiate pazienza
erano rimasti ragazzi che da questo
armadio qui usciva il nostro bell'uomo a
[ __ ] con te brutto non ricordavo così
brutto fermi e l'importante che già mi
aspetto anche questa chiusa non un
deficiente ma solo a patto di quadra mi
stuprare [ __ ] prima di tutto dove
devo andare così
ok giocato mai mai mai direbbe no ai
melo a gemma dall'amato stile e dobbiamo
ma corre di più ma cosa ma quando run
agua quando mai tocca mai neanche
toccato brutto deficiente mano mentre
dentro nell'armadio perciò provata è
legato mai mai mai mai vedove l'armadio
che non mi ricordi di sopra
no c'è il solo dentro sono le tre ok non
è vero ma sarai stronzo ma quando mi ha
visto entrare scusami non è possibile
dai ragazzi minchia ma è un ora che
provo ma cosa devo fare
un giusto ed era sì stronzo ma fate
entrare in un buco che egli è minuscolo
in confronto a lui
dove devo andare
che palle fa chiama spesso di seguirmi
si è cagato il cazzo sarà sarà salva
sarà una partita abbiamo fatto mi
spieghi l'utilità di star madio ho
trovato l'oggetto accennino a ecco poi
c'è un liquido dell'accendino quindi
sono a posto come scrivi delle docce mio
riempirà cellino come combustibile si ma
che cosa mi serve spiega qui è questa ma
basta ma vai via takuro è rimane lì tra
culo a curon un paio di gas
c'è un piano ha ricordato possono fare
ora fermi mi sono ricordato cosa devo
fare
allora c'è un si vede anche dalla
piantina che qui c'è un altro assai
infatti si vede che più scuro qua c'è un
coso qui in questo punto qualcosa non
sembra poi lo sapevo non sembra a posto
in questa tappezzeria non la devo tipo
scorticare col piatto scheggia di pianto
la fa chi è
non c'è una maniglia per cui non posso
aprire la porta come non puoi a prima
porta ma perché non c'è la maniglia ma
fiction calcio ma [ __ ] all altro
la maniglia spiegamento di sopra
ward nei sword di mortacci tua
no no zio però devi scendere dal buco
non è che adesso fa il cazzo che vuoi ma
perchè vi deve seguire a caso sto tizio
ok a non so perché dopo supporta non mi
segue più non mi vede più entrare lo
porta a porta e le idee stupido aveva
questo lo si era capito la v nascondendo
qualcosa nella stanzetta quindi è brutto
deficiente ma ci vado cosa nasconde
pervertito nicchia come mi sono caga
tissimo in mano takuro tua sorella tacco
testicolo sai bene ciao zio
sì credo di sì a parte il fatto che
hanno tentato di stuprare ilano 23 volte
però avevano un dettaglio del piccolo ho
capito come mi chiamo grazie di
ricordarmelo
hai visto anche tu quel mostro sì sì da
non credere che una creatura del genere
esista tutte le uscite sono bloccate
siamo intrappolati qui ma mi fai capire
una roba batte dove cazzo stavi mentre
io giravo per casa pare di sì
dividiamoci diamo un'occhiata in giro
controllerò il piano terra
ok buona fortuna sì però vabbè lasciamo
perdere piazza dove i consigli e mi
compagni ci sono dei deficienti quale è
mia parola ma dato niente e siamo punto
ea capo non è cambiato nulla
motivo svitto alla maniglia si prendono
la miglia molto poche quindi adesso
posso andare giù alla prima la porta
misteriosà anni della porta permesso
sono fatti j
a perché buio ha il solo accendino che
stupido anni posso fare
fantastico poi c'è una candela c'è una
candela si grazie alla vena accendiamo o
tipo già risconti alla madonna che è un
lampadario st candela chiesta tizia non
si vede
ho messo devo prendere con se sarò
omogenee ma chiave ho trovato l'oggetto
chiave della cantina ma perché se ti
capita qualche tisana fattela zio è
perché c'è una vita triste ha dovuto
uccidere la porta poi per forza su luca
che non c'è e le mani per averla posta
pronta deficiente fi 20 facciamo giochi
in avanti dietro avanti indietro avanti
e indietro
sei stancato posso chiederti una roba è
giusto perché no no scherzavo se vuoi
non si ti offendi non ti chiedo niente
finito è sfogato i tuoi istinti umani
anche se non sei un caso umano però va
beh si è offeso
che voi potrebbe essere tranquillamente
piazzato lì sotto appena esco non c'è
proprio conto cosa ho trovato che non mi
ricordo prima chiave della cantina
poiché c'è una cantina in questo gioco
manco lo sapevo da cantina e questa è
questa usate la chiave della cantina che
culo l'ho trovato questa era la voce di
mika la voce di ma dov era mica sono più
o meno così
vi prometto che alla fine della serie
tiro una testata al muro per ogni
battuta di merda che ho fatto ve lo
prometto ragazzi di sopra è qui che sta
qua dentro non mangia tranquillo io no
no no no tranquillo tranquillissimo
[ __ ] [ __ ] in cantina io sì tipo la
cantina frutta finiscono sotto la sedia
vabbè non può anche andare a controllare
che mi stupra ma se aperto devo correre
d'amico che non è che poi lo bello che
il suo sguardo si possa andare invadendo
si forza mai mai mai mai veloce veloce
veloce veloce come dell'obi nell'uliveto
zio mi spiano sfondo a tutto campo e con
altri tuoi siano nascondi stasta gabbia
rischio è a ingabbiarlo io per qualche
strano mondo tipo se lo faccio entrare
poi lo dribbla e riuscendo lo intrappola
dentro lo posso fare io nel dubbio non
salviamo la partita venerdì dio
micah micah p giuro che io ho fatto il
possibile per portarti via però tu non
mai voluto seguire mi hai freddo nato
brutta stronzate lo meriti si può
entrare qua dentro senza che qualcuno
urla io robe del genere tanto qua c'è
una chiave che non la posso prendere
perché troppo in alto giusto così
sinistra c'era qualcosa patente
amici che si spostava la serie vai vai
si chiama zia che dovevo raggiungere lo
scaffale
siamo ragazzi ho trovato l'oggetto
chiave della cella della cantina mica
quanta roba c'è che sarebbe la chiave
della cella della cantina
lo sapevo lo sapevo ma quanto sei brutto
coi capelli lunghi ma quanto può essere
brutto coi capelli lunghi zio mi chiama
ripigliati dai quando riesco a centrare
un buco la frase non dovette
interpretarla nel modo sbagliato
mai mai mai mai mai mai mai mai mai mai
mai mai mai giusto il buco su per il
buco non era avevo così cantare valle
madonna sta incartando vai vai vai
veloce veloce veloce non mi sono più
nomi se ogni volta che supera sto
portando mi seguono più non so perché
sembravi proprio [ __ ] prima prima di
diventare gigante quante stanze ci sono
il suo posto mi chiedo non capisco più
niente
la travata accendino dai figli a quando
non vedo niente so l'ansia rega
cos'è sta roba usata la chiave della
cella della cantina sì ma mi fai
accendere alla luce o devo andare avanti
così a caso aga grazie a voi accendersi
mi chiamo arrivato un messaggio mi sono
pagato in mano cos'è sta roba
mi ha ricordato che devo andare a fare
la spesa non si capisce
oddio così a è vero che devo vederla da
dietro le sbarre sta cosa
ma questa me la sua ricorda geniale
questa roba la geniale siccome ci ha
disegnato tipo dietro le sbarre e tu
devi leggere la scritta da dietro le
sbarre
537 cacciaguerra bali a sei un 6 sono
scemo che cosa me ne faccio di 5 stefano
rassegna sulle mutande che non me lo
ricordo permesso la porta è chiusa
dove devo ammetterlo straw dice datemi
qualcosa da aprire che ne so ho trovato
l'oggetto punta piatta cambi la puntata
cacciavite se potevo improvvisarmi
meccanico all'improvviso spiega mi a
buffalo si brutta come la fame ma taglia
tristi capelli ma è una donna e un uomo
ma quando sei brutto poi come fa a
essere così blu va dai sei la cosa più
bella io abbia mai visto ti prego dammi
il tuo numero che ti rimorchio pro dove
bene tanto prima e ma poco tanto la
madonna
se per cui lissimo ma riportavo madonna
cosa sei maciste cos'è sta roba è la
punta piatta la punta piatta cielo ho
capito a cosa serve il cacciavite sono
forte questa veramente andata cool
issima non lo sapevo me lo ricordavo mai
cinque miglia finalmente socia un senso
sta guarda 5376 trovato l'oggetto che
avete l'edificio annesso dell'edificio
annesso di qua purché vaca uscita dall
armadio come bastare lui nell'armadio
che grosso 6 molte meno ma come ok a
posto mi ha teso la trappola
c'è un bastardo dentro che siamo tornati
non mi fa scherzi eh
a santo dio grazie quindi questo quale
edificio annesso ragazzi c'è un altro
edificio non me lo ricordavo mai le case
ragazzi concluso fini secondo episodio
di toni che sta diventando sempre più
figo o meno che vado avanti non mi
ricordo più caso il contrario invece di
ricordarmi cose non me ne ricordo quindi
meglio così e nel prossimo episodio sarà
ancora peggio questo non sono sicuro
come al solito si vide vissuto solo un
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook come vi è stata una descrizione
se non sapersi discrete dici mi diano
fossero video belle ragazze
[Musica]